this is a production of cornell
university
all right good afternoon everyone um so
as not noted today i'm going to share a
bit of my research from my program that
spans a few different cropping systems
as well as spatial scales so we're going
to talk about agricultural practice use
throughout the united states
so it's well established that
agriculture is a major driver of global
environmental change you know in terms
of climate change biodiversity loss
soil degradation water pollution
and really there's been a lot of
stakeholders different actors throughout
the food system that have been issuing
kind of increasingly urgent calls um for
transformative change so not just simply
uh small improvements the sustainability
of our agricultural systems but
something a little broader a little more
radical
so here you can see some different
titles from some recent
peer-reviewed scientific articles
calling for this transformative change
both in agriculture
and in agriculture systems
we can see similar calls among uh social
movements so here's the cena this is a
transnational agrarian movement of
peasant or small older farmers calling
for
uh transformative change
and then we can look to some major
governmental bodies
that spend a lot of time talking about
uh policy both national and global
skills so
sustainable development goals or ifes
making biodiversity targets
so
there's a lot of different actors here
different stakeholders but we see a
common thread in terms of this focus on
transformation
but there's not a lot of agreement on
how we might get there so uh one way to
think about this though is this
framework here that i've adapted so we
have five different levels moving from
kind of a more incremental changes or
improvements in agriculture all the way
up to transformational changes in the
food system
so i'll walk you through this briefly
um
at level one we see this is really
focused on on-farm management practices
so increasing the efficiency of engine
use so things like drip irrigation or
split fertilizer applications
level two we're substituting
synthetic or otherwise perhaps
unsustainable practices with something
that's perhaps more equilateral so
compost use mechanical pesticides are
just a few examples
so these again are just these
incremental improvements to agriculture
and then kind of right at that threshold
um
moving towards more transformative
change we have this idea of redesigning
aggravated systems
and so this is a bit of a simplification
but we can think of this largely as
enhancing increasing
non-crop diversity as well as crop
diversity um
to really reshape these farm operations
these farm systems
this is a bit outside of my talk today
but i'll know that the last two levels
really would have been transforming the
food system as opposed to this
agriculture so
reconnecting consumers and producers
developing alternative food networks or
building we're creating a new global
food system based on important
principles that are often left out by
justice and equity
and so this is obviously going to
involve a lot of different factors it's
multi-scalar we're talking about things
like policy economic levers democratic
processes or different types of social
mobilization to actually realize these
types of large scale changes
what i want to mention though is that
a lot of the research so far
um really focuses on these first two
levels
a recent
study showed that when they assessed a
lot of the public funding in the u.s 90
to 95 of that work was focusing on
improving efficiency or substituting
synthetic practices for perhaps organic
or other ecological ones
and so when we're thinking about this in
terms of redesign and transformation
perhaps this is a bit of a challenge
here that we need to overcome
one way to think about this um is
through the lens of agroecology which
can be
broadly understood as kind of a holistic
integration
of different disciplines so social and
natural science disciplines as well as
indigenous ecological knowledge
a suite of farming practices which we'll
spend a lot of time talking about today
as well as a social movement which is
really what makes anger
unique and different than say
ecological intensification or some of
these other types of paradigms we may
think about in terms of these ecological
practices
and i'll spend just a brief amount of
time near the end trying to bring the
social movement component into this talk
um because it's really about the
confidence it's how these things come
together that's that's key
all right so when we think about
aggregate practices um there's a lot of
different ways to organize them one is
through the application
of their use so we can think about these
practices from a within field used to a
landscape level
and certainly they've been promoted for
a wide variety of reasons but one way to
think about them is due to the ecosystem
services or the benefits they provide
humans
um
and that gives you a good sense of why
we see a lot of research suggesting that
farmers
use these practices
so one service might be weed suppression
so this could be through inter-specific
competition wheat crop competition or
allelopathy with things like cover
problems or inter-profit
solar health this could be direct
applications or amendments
of organic matter for instance through
compost or turning under a cover crop to
improve soil health this could be
reducing physical disturbance with
reduced tillage
or protecting the soil from erosion
pollination um of course providing
different nectar
and other resources for these
pollinators you can also think about
this such as
um we should think about order planting
so hedgerows is also providing habitat
for perhaps ground nesting or the native
pollinators here
and then biodiversity really engages all
eight of these practices
um both through uh both in terms of
above ground biodiversity as well as
below ground so this is through the
provision of
these more rich diverse
uh habitats both spatially across our
agricultural landscapes and temporally
and i should say
these eight practices are obviously not
an exhaustive list of angry political
practices but they're the eight that i'm
going to focus on today
so in terms of my research um as as was
mentioned it's covered a few different
uh scales here
and the scope is somewhat broad and so
first i'm going to take you
basically discuss my work on four
systems focused in the northeast
uh so we're going to spend a little bit
of time with winter cereal gorges and
these dairy double cropping systems
and the trade-offs between yield and
nutritive value
staying in the northeast we're going to
shift to grain systems and i'll tell you
a little bit about my work with cover
crop based no-till planted soybean
production and the focus here will
really be on a multi-tactic approach to
weed suppression
um and then we're going to scale up to
the national scope and
focus now on fruit and vegetable systems
and in particular we're going to look at
the relationship between farm size as a
proxy for a wide range of
characteristics which i'll explain and
how those might influence practice use
and then spend a little bit of time on
motivations and deterrence and then
differentiate between individual as well
as structural
uh components there
and i also want to draw your attention
to the difference right or the scope of
kind of the different methodologies or
disciplines i used here so some of these
are more exclusively natural science
based
and then some of my latter work really
try to bring in social sciences and then
take a and then reintegrate it all and
take a mixed
approach
and just to give you kind of some higher
level takeaways right up front before we
get into each of those individual
sectors
for the forage systems
really this is about increasing crop
diversity so with these double cropping
systems farmers are now getting two
crops within a single annual
uh cropping season um
but what's also important is they're
reducing reliance uh
on these feed imports often from the
midwest or out of state and that's going
to really help localize or recouple
those nutrient cycles and so this is
where we're not really just interested
in you know
increases in efficiency or some form of
substitution this is about redesigning
and diversifying that cropping system
just to make that connection to this
analytical framework
for the grain systems um here our kind
of entry point is increasing non-crop
diversity so cover crops are key here
um and we'll explain a number of
different services those provide and
what's also important i think at least
when i reflect and think about this work
is how that encourages crop diversity
and so
this really speaks to the need to move
away from you know corn soybean
rotations
those are going to be really challenging
if you have low crop diversity to
actually use a system like this
and also
just the importance of trying to seek
out these uh you know synergies between
using multiple aggregate multiple
practices
and then for the fruit and vegetable
systems um form size i would argue needs
to be considered more when we think
about some of our work on these systems
um also when we're thinking of policy
uh there are some really important
differences among these different farm
sizes
and how they use these practices and we
could better support farms across the
range uh
i think there's also an important role
farmers can play for increasing practice
adoption again since i'm going to try to
tie this back at least a little bit to
that social movement component of value
ecology
and then i'll also make an appeal to
interdisciplinary research
to address these structural barriers
all right so for the first section
winter cereals and storage and double
profit systems
just to orient you to this work again
here we're really focusing on cover
crops and properties so there's two of
those practices
to be focused in the northeast maryland
and new york
in these systems for dairy farmers
so when we're designing this work the
context here
that's important is we're really
thinking a lot about climate and so what
this figure is showing you is that the
change in these very heavy rainfall
events and heavy precipitation events
we're seeing a big increase in the
northeast more so than in other regions
throughout the u.s
and
it's even predicted to continue that
trend um
throughout the rest of the century here
so
we're really thinking a lot about this
extra water in these systems and how we
might manage them
um
working with dairy farmers and thinking
about their particular
cropping system constraints or
challenges they might have there's been
some survey work and some work directly
to extension educators with a lot of
farmers in the northeast
and a number of key barriers have come
up to using cover crops and that's fall
planting timing so number farmers don't
feel like they really have enough time
at the end of the season so in that fall
to establish a winter cereal cover crop
after they harvest for instance corn
silage or something that's a fairly long
season crop
also they have a constraint in the
spring um they feel like it might delay
the planting of whatever that crop might
be
um so that's a bit of a constraint that
farmers would be hesitant to use uh
cover crops
and then of course costs labor time
seed costs other inputs
are a barrier to using this so
one way that some researchers also here
at cornell but certainly elsewhere
have tried to encourage the use of these
winter cereals over the over the fall
and winter is by
using them as a double crop so
yes we're still establishing them in the
fall but the benefits perhaps for some
farmers are a little more tangible
they're actually going to harvest this
to feed their animals
so this is where you're going to get an
increase of on-farm forage production
which is important they can also focus
on really high quality forage which is
key with eating different animal groups
which i'll explain briefly
um and then you're still getting those a
lot of the same benefits you're
protecting the soil from erosion you
might get some off cycle opportunities
to apply manure you're still going to
take up some of that residual and at the
end of the year
um so you still get a lot of those
benefits those environmental benefits
that we're normally encouraging farmers
to use cover crops for
okay so the objective of this work
really was to assess the trade-offs uh
between yield nutritive value and
harvest window
across multiple winter serial
species and cultivars
so it's just a brief overview of the
methods
as i noted the field sites are warm in
maryland
uh we used a randomized complete block
design three different species so barley
cereal rye and shrimp kaley and then we
had four cultivars of each of those
species
and then eight sampling dates sort of
sees it
we collected data on growth stage uh dry
matter yield and then a suite of
different uh forage natural volume
indicators so acid detergent fiber
neutral retributive fiber crude protein
and then 48 hour neutral detergent fiber
digestibility
um statistical analyses we use linear
nonlinear mixed effects models and some
custom contrasts and other post hoc
comparison methods
um
so what you're looking at here is some
yield data uh yield on the y-axis growth
stage on the x scale along the x-axis
and what's kind of a key takeaway here i
think is that
when you look at um x-45 which is the
boot stage so this is a key stage that a
lot of dairy farmers are going to look
to for trying to harvest what your
cereals as forage they can usually
obtain pretty high quality forage at
that time
um we see a pretty strong
separation here of
these trinically and cereal rye
cultivars from the barley cultivars down
here
and if you were to delay
uh let that yield get a little higher um
the separation just grows so
uh you also see that some of these
cultivars perform you know this tricky
culture
you see a couple performing
around performing the other cultivars
within that species but really the
takeaway is that barley
definitely produces substantially yes uh
lower yields than
steroid for the calorie and this will be
important when we're thinking about
trade-offs
so we didn't see differences between
cultivars so here these lines just
represent the three species
um
and on the y-axis here is relative
towards quality which is kind of a
summative assessment it takes in those
acid detergent fiber
neutral detergent fiber etc it brings
those all together in a single
uh a single value
so
just to kind of understand why this is
important if you're a dairy farmer
you're going to feed forage to different
animal groups based on the quality of
that forage so if you're trying to feed
a dairy cow within the first three
months of lactation
um you're gonna want at least
uh you know around 140 relative towards
quality um
so you need some really high quality
forage for those animals whereas if
you're feeding heifers or dried cows um
you could feed them uh potentially some
lower quality forage so you don't have
to say nutrient demands
so what you notice here
is that again at that heat stage of x45
all three of those species essentially
would be good enough to feed
kind of your highest nutrient-demanding
animal groups at least in terms of
cattle here
so
that's important especially farmers are
looking for that high quality on farm
forage production
if we delay a little bit you start to
see a big separation here
barley still uh maintains really high
forage quality whereas
triticale and cereal ride decline in
quality much more rapidly and so this is
important when we think about you know
harvest windows and timing um so there's
real obvious trade-offs here right
um so when we look at these harvest
windows you know looking at kind of just
your typical s-shaped logistic
relationship here for these phenological
models ordinal day along the x-axis that
just counts up from january 1st and you
have growth stage in the y-axis
and i've added a line here for that key
boot stage
and so what you're really seeing is that
cereal rye reaches that key boot stage
you know around four days earlier than
barley
six days almost a week earlier than
triticale and barley reaches that stage
uh you know two and a half days or so
earlier than trinity
this may not seem like a lot this is a
really busy time of year for dairy
farmers and so the difference of a
handful of days can really be important
when they have a lot of fieldwork to
take care of whether it's unpredictable
and when you see such you know fairly
dramatic drop-offs in terms of quality
uh you want to have a little bit of
flexibility to be able to capture a high
quality forage it's the whole point of
reproducing that forage on farm is to
feed
you know those those animal groups that
have high immunity demands
so when you think back to all this you
know these results i share and all these
data
it really is about a lot of trade-offs
so yield zero entry haley produced the
greatest yield barley in terms of
nutritive value it declined most slowly
that's an advantage
maturity cereal rye was earliest uh to
that boot stage which is obviously good
if a farmer wants to establish that
subsequent crop right this is a double
cropping system they can get that in the
ground earlier if they can pull off that
winter cereal earlier right
um
that harvest window ends up being
longest with barley if any of you
noticed it actually had the steepest you
know exponential growth phase or that
log phase of growth
uh with those phenological models but
that's somewhat negated by the fact that
it just maintains such high quality
across time that it still has the
longest harvest window
which is definitely a major advantage
but it has pretty low yield at least in
the northeast um
and which i didn't talk about what is
certainly important is coal tolerance or
winter hardiness barley has the lowest
cold tolerance
we even had issues with it around
tolkien's county here if you were to go
further north um you might run into
similar challenges and of course this is
where breeding could come in and help
out perhaps to some degree
i think when you look at this
collectively
one thing i perhaps point out is that
triticale although it doesn't perform
you know the best in in as many of these
different metrics or values it's a
really consistent intermediate performer
and perhaps in that sense it might be
pretty flexible and advantageous for a
dairy farmer to use
um and there has been a workaround here
on different types of summer annual
crops that would follow winter cereal
and i think that's really important here
when we're thinking about this you know
agri-ecosystem redesign so
shorter summer annual forage crops are
important so let's soar
[Music]
forage sorghum excuse me would be a
really key and important crop that's a
lot shorter season than say corn silage
and so this
this type of work whole system work is
going to be important for moving these
systems towards kind of a more of the
design phase
all right so shifting to the second kind
of major component of my work these
cover crop based no-till planted soybean
systems
um
we're going to now look at four
practices uh compost reduce tillage
cover crop and crop rotation we're going
to stay in the northeast in maryland new
york
but now we're like i said with these
grain systems
um so again with these uh with this work
we were really thinking about the
context for the the climate and its
impact on the soil in the northeast with
this extreme precipitation events
um so of course you've got to increase
soil erosion which you can see here in
early summer
in the soybean field
you're going to have more runoff this is
going to
cause a lot of adverse impacts on
aquatic ecosystems in particular you
know eutrophication
loading of sediment uh synthetics and
nutrients
um this could delay planting uh for
farmers also if it's really wet in the
spring and you have all that soil
exposed and then fewer days in the
fields that are workable
in contrast we have these cover crop
based systems which a photo taken at a
similar time
helps address a lot of these challenges
at least in terms of the erosive impacts
of precipitation we have this thick
cover crop mulch that protects the soil
it also provides organic matter and a
host of other ecosystem services which
i'll touch upon a little bit in
particular wheat suppression
so
not everyone in the room is going to be
familiar with the system so i'll do a
quick
overview of it to give you a sense kind
of start to finish of what this looks
like
so in the fall you want to apply a
little bit of compost we're expecting a
lot of different services from this
cover crop so it's not an afterthought
it's not something you just see that
there is easy quickly we need it to
perform well so
adding some compost in there getting
that seed planted earlier in the fall
possible
it's going to emerge
dormant
throughout the winter
when it resumes growth in the spring
um we're then hoping that's going to put
on a lot of biomass uh in particular
literature has shown that we should be
aiming for around eight megagrams per
hectare of cover crop biomass which is a
lot of plant material and this is
important a little bit later here
though
are slim well um once those cover crops
have reached anthesis so you can see the
answer is there it's a good indication
that there are maturity that
will result in good termination and so
that looks like
uh that looks like this you're taking a
roller crimper through the field
um it's bending those crops over at
their base it crushes that vascular
system and they slowly die leaving a
thick wheat suppressive mulch in the
field
um
[Music]
you can no-till plant uh right through
that mulch and in fact you didn't see it
in that short video on the tractor but
you can have a no-till planter on the
back of that tractor and complete this
in a single pass
um perhaps surprisingly these soybeans
actually emerge through all this biomass
their large seeded crops have good
energy stores they do make it out
through that mulch
uh a little bit later in the summer if
you've managed it well you should
hopefully see these nice fairly weak
free you know inter-row spaces a lot of
bomb must persist along throughout the
season
this image is also important for some of
the results i'll show in a moment um
here we're looking at some shading right
underneath the canopy these are 30 inch
rows
but we're interested in seeing those uh
that canopy closure uh in terms of wheat
suppression we want those soybeans to
shade out weeds and so
i'll speak more about that in a moment
but then of course in the fall it's time
for harvest
another important aspect of this system
in terms of context is related to wheat
emergence or reed periodicity
looking at some research here this is a
violin plot that shows where the
majority of these different species are
emerging
um this is npa but certainly relevant
here for new york in general we're
talking about the northeast and you can
see that common ragweed or bergeron with
sephora is emerging earlier than some of
these other species
this species
can also survive
rolling crimping um
and so it can be really problematic in
these
cover crop based systems in the
northeast so we wanted to think of ways
that we might
you know tackle this problematic species
in terms of the objective of this work
we wanted to terminate these cover crops
uh before during and after anthesis
so again thinking about that problematic
weed can we shift rolling time to maybe
uh manage it a little bit better and
then we want to look at the effects of
that on peppercorn biomass weed biomass
uh soybean yield and cover crop receding
so in terms of the experimental design
um again field sites in new york and
maryland uh this is a split block design
this time we have those same three
species
and four cultivars of each and here we
have four roll plant dates that span
generally kind of early may all the way
into june about a week apart um this has
obviously shifted a little earlier
further south in maryland
um and i'll just briefly point out these
photos were taken on the same day in
late july
um it may be a little hard to see but
there's a lot of winter cereal standing
up here in between the rows especially
in the early phase so those winter
cereals haven't reached anthesis when we
rolled so they didn't terminate as well
and this is where this reseeding aspect
comes in i won't really spend time today
talking about that but it's just to say
there are a number of different
components with this system
um that are important to take into
consideration when we're trying to
optimize it and find different ways
to manage you know weeds in this
instance
of course
later planting results in some yield
classes you can see these soybeans
haven't grown nearly as much by late
july
we collected a wide range of biophysical
data and then our statistical analyses
were linear mixed defense models and
then some structural equation modeling
or in particular uh a mediation analysis
so
i'm not going to use a lot of kind of
the jargon associated structural
equation mark modeling you know
exogenous endogenous variables we'll
talk about this simply uh we have four
factors here
carbohydrate biomass soybean density
rebound as a soybean yield
and asterisks indicate statistical
significance here um the thickness of
those arrows indicate the strength of
that relationship
and i'll explain a little bit what those
mean so first
what this is indicating is that if you
increase cover biomass you're going to
get a significant reduction in rebounds
right so this makes sense if you have
more biomass perhaps there's some
interspecific competition as those cover
crops are still growing but then also
when you roll it down it's going to have
that thicker wheat suppressive mulch
which is going to have a suppressive
effect
on
weeds
however if you produce too much biomass
lodging can be a problem so those winter
cereal species can fall over those
plants can fall over
and that's a problem because uh it's
really hard to
roll down cover crops that are already
toppled over in all sorts of different
directions we'll try to go through with
the no-till planter you need those crops
to really be parallel to the direction
that you're planting that soybean and so
what ends up happening is you get really
forced to show contact you can see large
gaps here in the rows
even see actually
a little bit of yellowing in these
soybeans because there was so much
biomass
competing for
scarce resources in the soil
and so we can see this effect in the fat
analysis here we see that coverground
violence if you increase it it has a
negative effect or it reduces soybean
density
and so why does that matter well as i
pointed out before soybean density um
making hasten canopy closure so we use
this is a
fairly very old um kind of cultural weed
management tactic that farmers have used
for a long time if you increase crop
density
uh you can increase uh canopy closure or
you can make that occur earlier in the
season and so this is what we do in this
system we use high sodium planting
grades to try to achieve brilliant
canopy closure
to help suppress weeds through that
shading effect and we're seeing that
here in the results of the path analysis
certainly uh we bought masses and the
menus that on
crop yield in this case
so this is all to say that it's all
these factors that are important
um and then we don't really want to be
just trying to maximize one component of
this system we're trying to look for
optimization here and so perhaps there
should be a new consideration of this
eight mega gram per hectare biomass
threshold
um and that multi-tactic approach to
weed management is definitely important
here we're using mechanical physical and
cultural approaches it's kind of many
little hammers or equal ecological lead
management approach
and then crop diversification uh
enhances the adaptability of this so as
i noted before this is going to be a
hard system in terms of timing if you're
working with very few main
brain cash crops if you only have corn
and soy this is going to be hard to make
this work even coarser corn soybean
wheat which is a little more common in
the northeast
i think some farmers still find that
that can be a little difficult um and so
if you have a broader diversity of crops
that you're working with there's just a
lot more chance that you're going to
success with a system like this and this
is how this is connected again to the
aggregate the system being designed
so for the final section um here we're
looking at fruit and vegetable
systems
so
this is gonna focus on all eight of
these different practices this is
national and scale
this time as opposed to the northeast
okay so a little bit of context
um
when we are starting with this work we
are interested in font size trends over
time
so what this figure is showing you the
y-axis here is proportion of total u.s
cropland um and then you have zero on
the x-axis here and over the past 30
years what you're looking at is some
pretty significant changes so larger
farms so farms that are at least 405
hectares in size in cropland hectares um
increase the proportion of land that
they're managing in the us by about 24
and we saw almost a similar reduction
for this kind of intermediate-sized
farms so farms that are 40 to 404
hectares
smaller scale farms so farms that are 39
hectares or smaller
saw very little change over this these
last three decades
we are curious though does this trend
hold for organic farms and i'm actually
not sure i mentioned this up front all
this work has been in organically
managed systems but a lot of these
different practices are of course
applicable to all forms of farm
management
um but
i was reminded of this as i'm looking at
the title of this slide here so does
this trend hold for organic farms
the data on this from the usda is a
little cumbersome to talk through so
it's easier to just explain it this way
um it's basically a small number of
large-scale farmers who are
predominantly conventional
but they have a small amount of their
land at least relative to the
conventional
acreage
under organic management
and they operate the majority
of organic cropland in the u.s
so
this
kind of phenomenon has been termed
conventionalization in the literature
and
there are a number of characteristics
that have been associated with this idea
of conventionalizing organic agriculture
so larger farm size
simplified angry ecosystems a
standardization of production and here
we're thinking managerially as well as
biologically
greater mechanization on these forms of
reliance on input substitution so that's
that level two when we're thinking of
that framework
so often farmers who are used to maybe
more conventional management are simply
looking for
you know organically approved inputs to
replace their synthetic inputs that
they're familiar with so that's that
input substitution
um these farms uh tend to focus on
wholesale which makes sense because
they're larger fonts so they're expert
oriented as well typically
and there's been a concern about a
dilution of organic standards or
weakening those
standards um
and coming out of this work is this idea
that there's a bifurcation from organic
farmers that you essentially have small
scale more artisanal producers um so
very little conventionalization um these
are highly diverse agri ecosystems and
that are kind of focused on direct sales
csa farmers farmers market farmers uh
relying on farm gate sales that kind of
system
and then you have your larger scale
forms which i was just describing highly
conventionalized um much simpler
aggregate systems and expert oriented
i just want to say of course there's a
range there's a spectrum it's sometimes
not that helpful to think about the
world in binaries
certainly have come across farms that
are very large and very diverse um
surprisingly so
um and those are real models i think for
some of the larger scale farms and
similarly you can find small farms that
necessarily aren't exemplary of all the
things you might associate with
agroecological diversified management
so
with all this in mind when we think back
to this framework our group was really
thinking well how does farm size perhaps
relate to this idea of incremental or
transformational change in agriculture
and is there any relationship here
between farm size and
efficiency substitution and redesign
practices
so we came up with this conceptual
framework here the y-axis is practice
use probability so one being highly
likely that you will use this practice
zero
not likely to use a practice and the
x-axis here
is form size and so
through this kind of conceptual
framework we're thinking that larger
organic farms are more likely to use
efficiency practices
um that there may not be a size
relationship or substitution practices
um based on form size
and then that smaller organic farms are
more likely to use those redesigned
practices
okay
so the objectives of this work we're
really to assess the effect of farm size
on these eight different agricultural
practices among organic vegetable
growers and then analyze motivations and
deterrence to their use
so in terms of methods uh took a couple
different approaches here uh our survey
was national
most states are represented here
uh i conducted 50 semi-structured
in-depth interviews in california new
york and so those farmers range from
less than half the hectare all the way
up to over 40 000 hectares that's an
enormous fruit and vegetable farm
um
data collection so we have quantitative
data through that electronic
questionnaire so this is through
qualtrics
uh qualitative data through all those
interviews um
all those reported interviews and then
data analysis i tried to take a mixed
methods approach here so we use
quantitative approaches like generalized
linear models so i'll show you some work
on the binomial logistic regression
we use multivariate techniques i won't
get into that here and then certainly
qualitative coding for all that in
different base data
so some results on the y-axis you're
looking at the total number of practices
used these are violin plots again the
width indicates the number of
respondents
uh that
indicated the number of the total number
of practices used here
and so you see those three main form
sizes also along the x-axis
so the takeaway larger farms use the
fewest number of agricultural practices
which is perhaps not surprising
although overall i think you'll know
that practice use is pretty high and
that's what we see across these eight
practices when we break it out practice
by practice
if you were to spend some time and look
at this
what you're really seeing is perhaps an
effect of a little bit of organic
certification requirements
um but you see fairly high use of a
number of these different practices but
i'll draw your attention
to three um for this talk here that we
do see some big differences
so small scale forms were at least 1.4
even upwards of two and a half times
more likely to use inter-cropping and
sector of planting and border plantings
than their larger scale organic
counterparts
so
if we kind of just focus on insectary
plantings for a moment here's a field of
brussels sprouts
on a 200 hectare organic farm in
california so this is kind of that
intermediate sized farm
so not a small farm these practices do
exist on larger farms and so what you
see here is strip intercropping with
cilantro and so this farmers let the
cilantro go to flower and that's going
to attract some beneficial insects to
help with biological pest control so in
particular this farmer's interested in
butterflies or circuit flies or more
specifically they're larva to help take
care of aphids and other pests of
brassicas
um
so it's one thing to see these practices
used on farms that are around 200 300
hectares or certainly are very small
highly diversified farms
um but how do we get it
how do we how do we feed these farms on
larger
farms like this photo i took out here in
california again that's much larger than
four and five hectares
i think if you look at the literature on
this um
especially if you look at some of the
meta-analyses and reviews and synthesis
um there's a very few consistent uh
results in terms of the determinants of
practice adoption especially when you
focus on individual level factors so
i mean kind of sociopsychological
factors here
uh some attitudes values behaviors a lot
of work tries to understand why farmers
are adopting practices based on those
types of
factors
um and so what i think is important is
that
we think a little bit more broadly these
these different individual
behaviors don't exist in a vacuum
context is important and there are
structural
structural barriers and so i'll give you
two examples from some of my
interview-based work
uh pulling some kind of representative
quotes
from farmers first on food safety and
then on labor policy
so here i'm just going to read you this
this quote from a farmer of california
you have to make sure you're checking
your traps every day and there's no
animal intrusion
i mean the sad part about it is buyers
want you to kill every living wildlife
around frogs if you see any open water
you try to clear it up or you put copper
sulfate in the ponds to neutralize them
if the frogs come out and they get your
spinach
that's it
buyers will say you know what we're not
going to work with this ranch anymore
because of this issue
so what i think is important in a quote
like this
is
this farmer is noting it's really sad
that he has to manage all wildlife with
such lethal tactics and i think it's
also important to note so this isn't
really reflective of perhaps his
environmental values you know this isn't
how he thinks about environmental
stewardship on a personal level
there are some structural forces here
that are that are kind of moving his
hand towards these management decisions
and what's also i think useful to note
is this is not a government policy this
is this isn't the food safety
modernization act this is from the
private sector these are buyers or
large-scale retailers that are imposing
these types of
restrictions on how this farmer's
managing their fields so that
that
you know
is a pretty challenging uh issue for i
guess us as researchers also to engage
with when it's private as opposed to
public
so as one more example here we'll look
at labor policy
so
i'll just read the quote again labor is
an issue for everybody it's an issue for
me because the increasing cost this
rising minimum wage is a burden on all
small businesses like myself
the price of corn the price of cucumbers
has not risen appreciably in the last
five years
my labor bill is up 40
not only does the wage go up all the
supporting costs to have influence go up
to so here he's thinking about health
care or unemployment benefits
um this is something that i heard again
and again with farmers i'm very
concerned about changes in the minimum
wage as well as overtime pay
farmers were very sympathetic and often
loudly supportive of a living wage this
isn't a small issue they wanted to take
care of their farm workers you often had
farmers talk about their farm workers as
if they're part of the family
they're also
squeezed here they have very thin
margins
i think a reading of usda data on farmer
profitability is kind of a grim reading
and so
there are a lot of options here and i
think sometimes when we think about
these issues uh there are policies
outside of the farmer's control
obviously that are having a really
significant impact on how they may
manage their forms
and so we were able to ask farmers about
this in our survey so here i'll bring
back a little bit of my survey data on
the y-axis you're looking at a portion
of farmers um in terms of respondents
again the same three form size
categories we ask them
how are you going to manage this
increase in minimum wage and that
differs state by state of course
california new york it's definitely
increasing more rapidly than in other
states
um what i want to just
draw your attention to is that um more
mechanization was an important way that
some farmers were going to manage uh
this increase in minimum wage
particularly as farm size increases
so these larger farms are already the
most mechanized
as you recall mechanization is also
largely associated with this idea of
conventionalization
larger and larger um
and so this is uh i think an important
you know finding in terms of how we
think about these changes in the organic
sector these farmers are looking to
remove
farm workers because of that economic
burden
so as one farmer noted we've got more
mechanization on the harvesting side
that we're focused on we have an r d
division that's trying to mechanize as
many aspects of harvesting as we can
i asked and what would you say is
driving this shift in focus and they
responded it's all driven by the minimum
wage hike
so
what i think's interesting about some of
these results is that when we talk about
agroecological practices we often think
of them as knowledge intensive
and labor intensive
um so we wanted to explore this a little
bit we asked farmers in the survey who
would use these different practices well
what is a labor requirement how are you
experiencing this
um
so it's a likert scale here from very
low to very high uh we got some
responses but we also asked farmers who
have never used those practices at all
well
what do you perceive the labor
requirement to be for using these
different agricultural practices what
would you expect of
how labor-intensive would you expect it
to be
and what perhaps is interesting when you
just focus on the high and very high
labor requirements you see that across
the board
farmers who have never used those
practices are perceiving them to be more
labor intensive than farmers who do use
those practices are reporting them to be
and this is where i think we can look to
some of the
research and just on the ground
experience of social movements this is
where farmer to farmer or peer-to-peer
sharing of knowledge is really important
so this is horizontal knowledge transfer
this is a key component of social
movements when we're thinking about
aggro ecology
and so this is one small way that for me
i see there being opportunities for kind
of this social networking approach and
it'd be a different way to try to
transfer knowledge than perhaps we
sometimes do if we want to see greater
adoption of these types of practices
across farms
so in summary for this section as we saw
large-scale organic farmers are less
likely to use just some not all but of
these aggregate political practices
barriers to practices are always
contextual they can also be biophysical
bearers which we can talk about today
but certainly that's an important factor
and they're often structural right
um big big picture things like food
safety regulations for labor policy
and um i would argue that scientists
should engage more with policymakers and
certainly with farmers when we're trying
to address some of these challenges that
farmers are facing in using things like
agroecological practices
um that's kind of an overall summary for
my work um let's bring it back to this
uh analytical framework here again we
were really trying to focus on level
three here right at that threshold
between
and transformational changes in
agriculture
and i think i'll just note that
transformative changes are non-linear
so when we think back to all those
resources
being spent on levels one and two that
increase efficiency or substitution
practices
empirical evidence doesn't show that
just because you've moved from level one
to two that you'll then continue on
towards you know a redesign and then
changing a local or global food system
or anything like that um so we need to
be thinking carefully about where we're
putting our resources and our time
towards um
the type of changes that we're
interested in seeing and so this is
where setting ambitious
interdisciplinary goals i think are key
and we want to make sure we're aligning
our research uh with the urgency and the
magnitude of the socioecological crisis
that we're facing so again
this is just bringing us back to those
calls for transformative change as
opposed to perhaps smaller more
conservative improvements in the dawn
and agricultural systems that we have
so with that i want to acknowledge um
there's a lot of people to acknowledge
uh here but certainly i'll begin with my
committee matt ryan rachel president
kerr and sunny power
uh project teams i won't lead everyone
out but the forged team was large
included people in animal science as
well as the soil and crop sciences
department a lot of different extension
educators and farmers
the grading team both here in the usda
in maryland
our vegetable group includes folks from
uh university california berkeley
university of british columbia the
nature conservancy and here at cornell
i couldn't have done any of this work
without former uh interviewees the pilot
study participants that really helped us
refine our tools in terms of both our
survey and our interviews
um and all the survey respondents that
took time out to
fill out a very long survey i didn't
mention how long that survey was it was
very long
um i definitely want to make a special
note to the food i recall the justice of
well-being collective i
deeply appreciated all the conversations
we've had with that group of graduate
students and postdocs over the years
those discussions have definitely
informed my thinking about food systems
and so i'm deeply appreciative of all
those
you know really intellectually enriching
conversations
ryan doesn't currently tomasulats and
that's everyone from
uh
our lab managers to undergraduate
research assistants and certainly all
the graduates and colleagues
uh folks at cscu in particular erica
stephen and lynn
were incredibly helpful as i worked
through a lot of different
a lot of different statistical
approaches
uh during my time here and i would like
to acknowledge the atkins center uh and
the natural sciences and engineering
research council canada for their
financial support with this work
and with that i don't know where we're
at with time but um you're happy to take
questions
[Music]
uh
[Music]
but then on the other side it wasn't
exactly
[Music]
[Music]
is
okay so great questions so yeah i think
well for at least uh when we were
harvesting those in new york for
instance i think the boot stage was
often
uh arriving around early may so not not
typically in april but yeah right around
that time
and that's where it's important those
noting
earlier the better so you can get that
subsequent drop in
um in terms of
uh how these are being fed to animals i
don't think they're typically being
conciled um so i think this is kind of
like fresh chopping fed
um i would say i'm not a dairy expert on
the side of things here i spend more
towards the field management there but
um i don't think these farmers are
saying styling it for a long time
[Music]
right so that's and maybe i didn't make
that clear enough so that would be the
double cropping system right so
the key part of that is getting two
harvests within that same calendar year
so you're getting that first harvest
there let's say early may of that winter
cereal maybe at boot stage maybe a
little bit later you're feeding that to
your animals then you're planting
something like corn silage or maybe that
forage sorghum um and then harvesting
that that same year just obviously maybe
in august or september
that's a good question i um
it's a tough one to answer i i guess i
would say well maybe the easiest answer
is an interdisciplinary method i find
at least for myself i find it
interesting to engage with a couple
different methodologies so it was nice
to bring in let's say be able to
exercise some skills i've gained you
know
doing some quantitative analyses but
then have this really rich
granular
interview based data so these
qualitative data um that i might code
and think really carefully about and
relate to a lot of different social
science theory and try to bring those
together that for me i think was an
important way to really get at some of
those structural barriers i think it can
be really hard
to do that just through survey work for
instance in particular if you only want
to deal with one i think be able to have
conversations with farmers
you're more likely to get at some of
those but um survey works deceptively
difficult to do
some people i'm sure can even get at it
with carefully worded questions
yeah
did you do the qualitative interviews
before the survey or
kind of the same time we did a few i did
some pilot uh well i did a number of
different pilot studies but i did do
some interview work first so
things like food safety for instance um
not being california
and having spent the number of years
previous kind of with my head and the
grain systems i wasn't necessarily
thinking about food safety but then
doing some interviews that was very
clear i needed to be talking about food
safety regulations for talking about
fruit and vegetables and that was really
coming up as influencing practice use
and so for instance that informed some
questions on the survey so i do think
doing some focus groups whether that's
a small group of farmers or a handful of
individual interviews is really
important for informing a certain tool
jeff i was wondering you know where does
kind of consumer
costs come into this and i'm thinking
here
you know we're always trying to have the
lowest price for our consumers obviously
that makes a lot of sense and you're
hearing these growers saying we're gonna
not you know mechanize so we're gonna
have fewer folks there
a lot of that money is not getting to
the farmers i mean it's pretty clear
that it's the middle person how does
that kind of
impact or did you hear from hey if we
only got more money
you know from from the actual you know
consumer that we would be in better
shape to you know incorporate some of
these tactics and we just can't
right i mean that's
honestly one of the major issues that we
kept coming back to in interviews that i
don't necessarily
have an answer for these farmers which
yeah i probably didn't make clear enough
in the presentation but um
yeah it's
these increases in say labor costs labor
is often the largest indirect costs on a
farm
the farmer's absorbing that it's not the
wholesale buyers or processors and it's
not the supermarket retailers typically
they're trying to keep those prices low
right and i had some i mean i just
didn't have time i had some other quotes
that are
i think a lot use a lot stronger
language about how they've been treated
by some of these large-scale buyers they
have very little negotiating power
sometimes
and
um
you know yes if we increase the price of
food uh would that help if the farmer
was able to get some of that back i
think that's where direct marketing can
help farmers are working directly with
consumers
um but then of course you have millions
of americans that are food insecure
right now so
even at the very cheap prices and cheap
in quotations
of externalized costs but that's that
one is and this is i guess
the types of questions that i find
interesting because they are so
complicated and bring in so many
different
dimensions here but i don't have any
simple answer for that it did
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu